from what i recall you were living with
a single mom
she had three kids from three different
daddies
she was banging all of the daddies
and
except well
i'm assuming that you had some some time
with her otherwise you would have left
sooner right yeah um so she's basically
banging four guys at the same time
and you're essentially the beta bucks
part of the equation you weren't making
a lot of money can you kind of fill in
the blanks there and just let people
know what the starting point was and
what brought you to all this i was
actually making around 100 000 at the
time but i saw myself as a 2 out of 10
right so i weighed 115 pounds and she
was the hottest girl i've ever met right
so it was like 115 pounds
yeah dude i was really light dude like
how tall are you i'm five foot nine now
five foot nine hundred and yeah that's
that's really light yeah yeah i like
malnutrition right and so i didn't eat
now i'm up to 165 after watching the
show and and doing the work but anyway
so i saw myself very low
what are you at now like what did you
level up to as far as your you know
physical appearance i'm at 162 in weight
and i mean it's just like i don't know
if you can see my but it's just all
muscle like i'm getting there the
shoulders are coming in the back's
coming in
um i didn't end up with a single mom
with three kids from three different
daddies
i found her on facebook and she invited
me over and she was thought i mean she
looked so good right and it was like
i didn't get laid for a year before that
and if it was it was like ones and twos
but
she really ruined my life to the point
of suicide rich like um
i i i fell in love with her because i
figured that was the best i could get at
the time and i i didn't have a father
growing up i've done like 10 years of
therapy to get over that [ __ ]
what happened to your old man when you
were growing up did he did he leave that
was yours or what happened he kicked me
out of the house at 14 with my dog so we
went we went like homeless til i was 18.
okay so you had a father until 14. but
why did he throw you out of the house
uh he just wanted something different i
guess and he was on a prescription pain
pills and got addicted
and uh it just a very bad
environment his father did the same
thing to him so maybe it runs in the
family i don't know but
but other than that man i fell in love
with this girl
to the point where it was like
i couldn't let go once i found out that
she cheated on me a lot like these guys
reached out to me did me a favor and i
still called her and begged her to take
me back like it was pathetic dude so all
three of these guys reached out you said
hey john two of them did two of them
yeah yeah you know heads up she's she's
coming over every once in a while one of
them is my one of my good friends now so
okay
and he's crushing it in life too but
okay but they they were alphas you know
that they had she had kids with these
were
big strong men that compete so how old
was she
25 and how old were you at
uh 29. she managed to rack up three kids
from three different guys by the time
she was 25 yeah dude the oldest was like
11 so she did you have what all this was
like 11. yeah like when she was like 16
she had a kid or something crazy no 25
11. you're talking 14 dude not well 14
she had a rough life okay so like were
there any like red flags going off any
bells or anything like little voices
said yo dude you want to do this dude my
whole stomach and that's how i found
your [ __ ] video sorry youtube
freaking videos is um
is i was googling should i date a single
mom and i found all this content saying
john don't because dude i knew in my
stomach first off one to one i with if
she didn't have kids i didn't qualify
for her like if you just took the kids
out of the equation she was she was nine
out of ten without kids right i didn't
qualify so in my stomach i knew
something was wrong
so i started doing research about single
moms and the problem is i found your
videos and rejected the advice okay i
said why did you reject the advice when
you first came across it
because i was so desperate to have
companionship from her was there
something in the advice that offended
you or you just think no i was wrong
i just needed to be proven wrong you
know okay and i think a lot of men that
well so you went looking for answers you
found answers you didn't like the
answers did you go looking for other
answers somewhere else or did you just
kind of like compartmentalize those
compartmentalized and then uh after a
breakup i just started listening to you
exclusively like i deleted apple music
and just listened to richard cooper
and it's changed my life so where was
like
like what was the aha moment that that
like said that like force you to say to
yourself okay like john this is stupid
you know this needs to stop
with the single mom or with my life in
general yeah starting starting with
ending that
relationship
well it was when she she so i told her i
was done after like i figured out she
was banging those guys and then
she called the police on me saying that
i broke all the windows in her house and
i was in arizona at the time she was in
utah so i had a sheriff meet me in
arizona prove that that was wrong
so i was supplying you know funds to
this woman you know i made a hundred
thousand a year
i saw myself as a low value guy that's
fine
but she went like bat [ __ ] she's crazy
uh on me and then then she said i was
harassing her and went to like i was a
stalker then i broke all the windows in
her house and i just immediately like
left states i just did just
just just to move away for a while so
aside from the other guys reaching out
to you and say hey you know she's you
know she's coming over
um did they alert you to any other red
flags with her that you previously just
ignored yeah domestic violence like two
of them had domestic violence cases
against false are real
uh false to their perspective real to
hers okay so false
yeah so that's the line with her like
walking around the house and smashing
her own windows on and trying to blame
you for it yeah yeah yeah yeah so that's
like one of the things that i'm always
trying to tell guys is like you know
like like there's all these little alert
signals there's these red flags whatever
is that you want to call them that that
will pop up
and you can either pay attention to them
and respect them and then walk away from
problems or you can just cast them aside
say i don't know that false domestic
violence that guy was probably an idiot
sort of thing until it happens to you
right and then you get a phone call from
the police department saying hey you
know would you break this lady's windows
and you have to go and meet with the
sheriff to go and prove that you're in a
different state
so
okay so you're
so you're skinny
relatively well off for your age yeah
definitely the wrong relationship did
you just leave a dear john letter and
pack your bags and leave overnight like
yeah no i just started driving that day
and listening to your podcast like and
it became a habit like i cried i was
like still beta crying i was weak for
about three weeks i had good support in
arizona good friends to like
that were more red pill that were like
dude john you're
don't ever do this again like that
single mom three kids you know how
expensive that is you make money you
don't make that much money so um how
long how long were you with her for by
the way
seven months
you could have been on the hook if you
were there for longer to pay child
support to those three kids
in utah yeah because she even said that
we were married like she had this fake
engagement ring she would wear yeah yeah
all right so okay so you bounce and then
and then you walk away from that crap
relationship and then you change a lot
of aspects of your life because you
change your physical appearance and you
also change your ability to make it rain
you know to make some banks so what did
you do there oh testosterone uh so the
reason why i was so skinny so apparently
when i was 14 i was put on testosterone
taken off early so it screwed up my
hormones my body naturally just wouldn't
produce any testosterone my levels were
like low 100s or something like almost
to the point where it's like i was a
woman
so i got on testosterone three or four
months later i started
but i was also going to the gym at this
time but gaining no weight there was
something wrong and the moment that trt
started working like
people started i didn't notice it but
people said the way that i'm treating
them is more dominant and like mature
and i just started progressing in my
business my i've been running this
business for four years and it was until
like two months ago we just landed our
biggest contract so did you ever did you
ever see the uh hubermann
interview um i think it was with
friedman he was talking about how
like the entire purpose of testosterone
is to make effort feel good oh yeah and
i tell my friends that unfortunately my
best friend who it was on trt he just
passed away but
um like i told him that it makes effort
fun and i get up at 5am to go running
with the neighbors i live in this like
okay so i bought a house right a really
nice house in st george utah
super conservative out here and my
neighbors we they're old i mean there's
no one my age with a house where i live
and we go running in the morning my
network is up i'm
and it's just like the effort of waking
up is more fun i used to just sleep in
all day right and then go run to single
mommy right for a companionship oh
please take me back i love you
why did they um why did they put you on
testosterone therapy when you were a
teenager
uh because i wasn't growing i was uh
five foot two through high school i just
wasn't growing really i'm five foot nine
now yeah yeah so like i just
i and i was also smoking cigarettes by
like 12 like my parents were
real winners you know
so
yeah it was uh i was malnourished
growing up no protein
and then they put me on testosterone to
make me hit puberty what's the reason
okay and that kick started that and they
pulled you off that yeah and then then
it made my whole body never get used to
supplying testosterone so once i got put
on it it was like
you know frying pan hit me in the face
as you said like everything seems
different colors are brighter i work
harder i go to the gym like do they ever
try hcg as a therapy to restart your own
endocrine system or do they just go no
but i get i get hcg shots with my
testosterone shots right but i mean like
when you were a teenager they didn't try
that okay i don't i don't think so i
don't remember much okay all right so
so you've moved out you left that behind
there's no ties there's no legal issues
there's no
he played the role of daddy you got to
pay support here it was only a short
period of time for seven months you got
in you got out you learned your lesson
what did you do to change your ability
to earn income
uh okay this is going to sound crazy but
i believe our subconscious can change
the way we think and
if you're listening to hip hop music f
women get money all day
that's like
four high value people that can do that
but it does nothing for you so when i'm
in the gym i'm listening to business
books audiobooks your podcasts when i'm
driving i do a lot of driving when i'm
bored i'll just drive 12 hours to
arizona go see friends and i just fill
my subconscious with good content and
it's really changed the way i
output deal structure deals my
motivation so i don't even have apple
music anymore i just listen to you i've
said that for a long time that um you
should turn your car into a learning
center yeah yeah yeah yeah call it a
university or whatever i got that from
you because you can get like a master's
degree in anything you want yeah i got
that from you honestly you'll learn a
lot more listening to good books or
podcasts in your car than what you will
sitting in the classroom jotting down
notes
yeah for sure the most successful people
in the world will share their wealth on
audiobook podcasts and when i say wealth
like i'm talking about knowledge right
yeah wouldn't you rather have like you
know
jc maxwell talking to you in the air
versus you know f women get money pop
hip-hop music i mean it just her elon
musk podcast i mean come on yeah that'll
that'll i mean like the whole f women
get money is okay maybe you might need
to shift your mindset like don't get
distracted go find your purpose but
right
what are you doing now that you've you
know figured that out so okay so i mean
you turn your your car into a learning
center
um
what else did you do aside from from
getting on testosterone therapy to to
get your endocrine system working i mean
you change your diet like did anything
else yeah go because you put on quite a
bit of weight i mean you went for 115
pounds 165 you said yep in about a year
in one year yeah i just tagged you on
that post from that starting point yeah
um
is it okay if i show it to people yeah
please please do and see if i can pull
it up
um and i i'm bigger than that photo that
photo was last month i added another six
pounds this month so
i got a damn but it was diet man it was
all diet give me a full gram sending me
a security code i have to punch in
i just displayed all mine no hold on a
sec i gotta put it on my desktop i'll do
it
come on
yeah save info
there we go
so i saw this post here there was a
before and after there it is
yeah you were skinny as [ __ ]
hold on a second
what's that
there you go so this is the before and
after
yeah that is
that
dude is i spent 30 hours a week in the
gym
yeah yeah and i ate a lot
so i mean like let me ask you this
question because i mean one of the
things that
i find interesting is i you know i say
well here's some interesting information
like i'll i'll take a map and i'll plot
some landmines out like single mommies
you know crazy women borderline
personality disorder you know doing
stupid things that don't serve you i
kind of plot them all out and people go
oh that's that's that's not worth it
it's too much work and they kind of go
down this like doom and gloom sort of
black pill sort of part of that everyone
does i get it yeah did you ever go to a
place where it was like
it's hopeless
no no not when i found you it was
hopeless when i was dating her and when
i broke up with her but once i found
your podcast i didn't grow up with a dad
right so it's like
i got coached by the world's best father
this is gonna sound really weird and i
don't mean to say it like that but it's
like i was getting coached by like the
world's best father
all the time and it came down to
business finance and women
and it worked i mean i i think
i can't recall one thing that i've
followed to the t that hasn't worked
that you've said so
and i mean my bank account reflects it
you know my personal houses i just
acquired a gym so i'm a gym owner now so
i mean like there's you can't make this
stuff up and
so there is not one piece of content
that did not work for me that you've
meant to do i just think men have to hit
their breaking point
do the doom and gloom and then it's
their choice right it's like it's not
easy this was hard do you know how hard
it is to work out for 30 hours a week i
mean it's
and eat that much it's brutal man but
yeah well
that's what i want to talk about a
little bit too because i mean
you're very skinny
you know to start out with you're in a
real bad relationship your head's on you
know it's basically screwed on backwards
um
you weren't
making huge bucks you know at the time
but
some guys just kind of go to a place
where they're just like that's it i
don't i don't want to deal with life you
know they just kind of go like unplug
and they just kind of like go full on
mgtow or they just go like full on black
pillar i'm just going to stay away from
all this it's just not worth it but
like how did you find the worth in it
like
what would because i don't hate women
i think women
it's fun
right yeah yeah i don't hate women i
don't know why people think this show is
about women are great marriage sucks
yeah i would never get a different thing
i would never go down the divorce so my
okay my uncle he'll never watch this but
he made half a billion dollars working
for 50 years right
and he sold his company his wife took
half his money within three years and
it's like i got a personal testament to
this and it's like dude i would never
ever get married and right now i have
five girls i'm dating and one's in the
other room and
just it's it's it's easier they're all
cool with it too
was there anything that you came across
that i talked about in any of my videos
was like no he's full of [ __ ] with that
one that one's totally not true like is
there anything that didn't um no but
there was a thing with sean t that i
agreed with about spinning plates like
at the time i was like
shanti was like oh i don't like that
word and i was like i could see why that
would be bad but then i got over it
because now it's in my terminology but
that's it yeah well i mean he didn't he
didn't really disagree with um
the notion of
exercising some options he just hated
the term like right and i get why he did
he's a counselor i get it like
whatever
the fighting tournament you know it is
what it is yeah i know it is it's like
saying i hate the sun for being called
the sun it's just the sun it's just what
it is man yeah
water's wet women are hypergamous and
solipsistic end of story go do the work
yeah the hypergamy thing that was so
cool to watch once i put on the muscle
and like the girls because there's the
girls that i would see at this gym that
when i first got there i was skinny and
now they're approaching me at the gym
just like hey john how's it going and
it's like a complete 180 you know i went
in there this little weak guy could
barely bench the bar at what point did
that change for you like was it
when you hit 150 pounds when you started
to you know started getting some results
three months ago yeah but i've been i've
been picking up women um
i think probably two months after that
photo was taken i started
practicing spinning plates and they
weren't they were fine
for you at first because i mean it
sounds like you're really plugged in and
yeah okay scared man i was scared
scared of them like leaving right
because i didn't have too many plates so
i was terrified i was like okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna
maintain some frame here and i was
terrified to send the text but guess
what happened she responded with with
encouragement like i was like what no
you know what i mean like it turned her
on that i put her down like
and i don't mean put her down in a bad
way just like i i softly rejected her
and made her want me more
so
okay so the strategy of exercising some
options and dating several women
simultaneously in a non-monogamous
fashion aka spinning plates
has been working for you
yeah
especially today do they ever protest or
push back is there a lot of [ __ ] tests
do they ever scrap with each other yeah
but i i i
so two days ago there's the door i had
to there's the door to this girl you
taught me that and she walked out and
then sent me this long text sorry it'll
never happen again right comply or
goodbye actually no she's in the next
room right now she's back now so she's
obviously flying yeah she's compliant so
what was the fight
why did you have to show her the front
door she was just complaining something
about the dog hair on the couches and i
was like well you could clean it and
she's like what i was like well that's
the rule bye yeah it just escalated it
was a dumb escalation like
it was
pointless but what about some of the
other concepts you know where um you
know where i talk about maintaining
frame you know as you're dating women or
you get into an ltr like if you found
ways to apply that
i would never get into an ltr
right but i mean if you're dating a
bunch of these women like let's say
you're dating three or four of them
simultaneously for six months i mean
you're basically
spinning multiple plates in long-term
relationships right so there's
always the concept of managing frame you
know when it comes comes to women have
you been able to test that and apply
that i mean like the the the uh dog
issue is basically a uh [ __ ] test you
know like a dog and hair and sort of
stuff you're like well your dog's over
there you know the doors over there over
there
yeah yeah do you find that that's easy
for you to do now yeah absolutely
and they love it they respond to it they
respect it it's like
at first before you find your content
you're chasing single mommies like
you're so scared that there's gonna be
no one else out there there's so many
there's so many hot women out there
there's not a lot of high value men
so like men need to level the hell up
like asap
because there's a lot of attractive
women i can find 20 tomorrow so
beautiful women are not a scarce
resource out there guys it's uh high
value top shelf guys that can put a dent
universe know how to make bank live in a
strong masculine frame you know have
combat skills these guys are rare super
rare and
it's you know it's going to be dressed
in overalls and look like work when you
start to you know to begin to do it but
the payoff as you can see with john
himself because he did it himself how
long did it take you to turn around your
life like what was the total time frame
from leaving single mommy to today
a year
one year yeah one year you did all that
but i'm talking i'm talking 80 90 hours
a week yeah well yeah because you've
worked yeah because you committed
yourself to it right there was nothing
more important it was it i was at the
point of suicide when i broke up with
her like right and i had two options
it's like okay call quits or go play the
game with rich in my ear and i was like
okay i got a coach imagine me it's like
the super bowl and you're my head coach
bill belichick right whatever
and you're telling me to make that pass
what about the money part of it because
i because i always get guys you know
asking me about business and business
ideas so what about the money part of it
because you went from a hundred thousand
dollar year salary guy like what are you
doing
my now company okay um yeah it was my
own company called preferable pups and
we match people with people looking for
puppies i love dogs is my thing okay and
it just was an underperforming business
basically i i
was able to take 100k out each year but
as of three months ago i started
applying really aggressive um sales
skills and
basically networking with these
high-profile
dog companies that i can't disclose but
i just signed a three hundred thousand
dollar six-month contract
i have one employee so that's net profit
300 000
in my pocket for six months worth of
work so and we're able to satisfy that
contract on automation so it's kind of
feel free to check it out i mean
my linkedin as well is open to the
public i mean
i just can't disclose the partner but
can you can you talk a little bit about
your um
pivot like your shift in your business
mindset like like what would like if you
could attribute one two or three things
let's say to the success that that
you're having now versus where you were
at a year ago what would you say that it
is or all the things that are playing to
win
listening turning my car into a
educational studio right and
testosterone
i mean seriously
i i can't put it any simpler than that i
just i got off another deal called today
with a big they're called pet plan
and they're the biggest pet insurance
company and they're so excited to work
with me so it's like
just the conversation and dear deal flow
is just dominant and frame i use frame
control in business now and i get a lot
more done like it's crazy you use and
with my family i've cut off family
members due to frame control so did you
find that hard to do
no i hate my family so like that was the
easiest part like it was harder to cut
off women than it was my own family so
why would you cut off family like what
is it about them where you're like okay
this is just not acceptable i'm going to
keep them at arm's length or is it just
like a fair ghost like you're never
talking about they're mormons so i'm not
a mormon
um their values do not align with my
values it's very hard to have
conversations with them okay
got it it just doesn't make sense right
like to go over for thanksgiving and
what are we going to talk about i can't
i can't contribute to the table
what like what were the problems if you
don't mind talking a little bit about it
like was it was it like constant
lectures about your lifestyle and they
wanted yeah it's all always right but
they were they my family are all
entrepreneurs so it wasn't that it was
just like
you know lds they don't believe in
multiple partners well they do but they
as long as you're married to all of them
right but you know they can't do that
anymore like legally but there's like a
traditional list i don't know lds are
weird but
um
no it's just it's about values right
it's like i drink coffee you can't drink
coffee if you're mormon it's like those
nitpicking conversations aren't worth my
time got it
got it so minimizing stress and all of
that freed up more of your time for the
pursuit of excellence in doing the work
then is what you're saying like you made
some
discriminatory choices about what you're
doing with your day like i can listen to
[ __ ] ain't [ __ ] but hoes and tricks
on the radio or i can turn on a podcast
or an audio book i can
spend an afternoon with people that are
going to lecture me about my lifestyle
choices or i can you know go to the gym
right
i did have a question for you though um
you talk i i don't date women with
tattoos um
well i'll have fun with them i have
tattoos and i started getting them
removed what do you think how does that
apply for men though do you think as a
man you can have tattoos and then i just
don't want to sound like i'm
contradicting myself or being a
hypocrite yeah i don't think it matters
for men because tattoos are a
traditional traditionally masculine um
endeavor it's it's you know it's always
been that way especially in like like
there's even tribal cultures in yeah in
tongans africa and australia where they
like tattoo their bodies and it's not
the women that are getting tatted up
it's the guys that do
so
when women do like it's like it's the
whole
you know if i can put it this way it's
it's women trying to be more masculine
and mimicking the behaviors of men right
so getting getting like sleeve tats you
know for example
it looks fine on a guy right like i've
seen lots of guys i have friends with it
i've got enough scars already like i
don't need anymore so i'm just not into
it right but um
when you see women copying those those
behaviors it just tells me that
something's offside with the mental
firmware um
and a lot of the stuff that they're
putting on their body is self-mutilation
right yeah yeah yeah
so single mommy she had a tattoo trying
to cover up her scars on her stomach
i've seen that a few times she couldn't
even finish it it was a half done like
bird cage and it was the
weirdest whenever i felt her stomach it
was like goo like it was just the
weirdest and she was the hottest girl at
the time that i've ever been with and
now
i mean i say i can attract
i can easily land a seven and an eight
when before it was a two and a three or
a single mommy so like i'm more happy
with a compliant six or seven than a
non-compliant 9 10 or 11 yeah a pleasant
seven is always better than a [ __ ] ten
all dude i've had them all i i paid for
them too so jimmy's got a question for
you here about your gym routine uh so i
do push pull leg split
that simple and sometimes i do a cardio
for sundays as my day off but i'm in the
gym seven days a week
if i do
anything extra it's those fufu exercises
like you can hit your deltoids a certain
way or
but that's it i mean i it's just stick
to a plan lift heavy [ __ ] put it down
like rich says you're good to go
you gotta eat well yeah i don't my abs
aren't visible
because of the bulking process so when i
start cutting the trt should help with
that with the muscle it's wasting i'm
sure
and um
i'm looking forward to that but whatever
you can fast like you know throughout
the day basically like you can have your
last meal at six seven o'clock and then
and then your next meal can be like
lunch time right or like one o'clock or
two o'clock and have it as a big meal
because i don't i i'm not done growing i
wanna i wanna hit like you'll still grow
you'll still grow but it's but it's just
your body will start to burn more fat
while you're in the fat fast
right i like you're not going to lose
any muscle like that like that usually
tends to happen if you're doing like
multiple day fast like two three four
day fast that's when your body starts to
like cannibalize muscle tissue because
it's a good source of energy
and a lot of your fat starts to go then
too our bodies don't give a [ __ ] about
us like it's like it could take the fat
but it's like nah i'll take the muscle
yeah it's about
i hate that man yeah it's about survival
is really what your body is yes like
there's lots of evo psych books so
recommendation for you you know since
you're kind of going through all this
unplugging sort of phase um for yourself
in the pin top comments of all my videos
i got an amazon link
and there's yeah there's books there
that i recommend with evo psych
listen to some of those because you're
because you're really going to fully get
your head around
what women are and what and what men are
and what our places and roles are you
know like basically here on the earth
so as you're kind of like moving through
life now now it's like okay well i've
i've seen rich's videos i've read the
book i've seen you know you know whoever
in the space that i collaborate with
um
then then you start to understand like
the science behind it all right and the
dynamics between men and women and why
you do what you do and why you have
those
limiting um you know those barriers that
you put up you kind of draw like a
perimeter around yourself and and
keeping us versus them sort of strategy
check some of those out because you're
going to like them did you recommend the
evolution of desire evolution desire is
a good book yeah yeah so you recommend
it it was fantastic yeah oh
i totally recommend that book
i would say listen to it twice because
there's a lot there it's very dense
but yeah what i was trying to the point
i'm trying to get at is like i think
most men watch your videos and then go
back home and beat off and play video
games and if that's who you are i mean
good for you keep watching the content
supporting the channel but you can
totally turn your life around but it's
going to be the hardest year of your
life for sure cool
you